Airplanes are not all that different from
tall blue police boxes… they use psychology,
design and research to make you think: it's
totally bigger on the inside!
Early jet airplanes like this 707 had interiors
designed for comfort, but based on research,
psychology, and design… planes today are
completely different.
We visited Boeing's Customer Experience Center
in Washington state to see how they conceptualize
a space, that's essentially a flying tube
-- into something more!
When you're flying in an airplane, one of
the needs you have is really to be quite connected
to the sky.
So, there's many ways that you can have that
manifest in your designs.
That's Blake Emery, he's the Director of Differentiation
Strategy for Boeing.
in the airplanes that we're creating now,
we're moving the windows to a different place.
We're making them larger.
So now, if you look around this airplane,
as an example, 787 Dreamliner, it doesn't
really matter where you're sitting, you have
access to a window.
You can look out the window.
Therefore, you have connection to the sky.
Something as simple as reminding people they're
skybound makes people more comfortable -- surprisingly,
even if you're afraid of flying.
A 2005 study done for the European Space Agency,
found living in confined spaces can cause
strain, unless there's a window…
It's somewhat counterintuitive, but the idea
of having the windows accessible to everyone
actually can help relieve some of that fear.
Because a lot of that fear is actually related
to the claustrophobic aspect of it.
When Yuri Gagarin became the first man in
space in 1961 his spacecraft -- Vostok 1 had
a window!
It turns out, that was one of the most powerful
parts of that flight.
For some reason, humans need to see the outside.
While airplanes can feel small they are actually
quite large.
A Boeing 747, has
over 31,000 cubic feet (876m3) of space, larger
than the area of a six bedroom house.
Imagine 250 people in a six bedroom house.
It would feel crazy crowded.
To make a space that size feel livable for
hundreds of passengers involves a lot of psychological
"tricks," as Dr Rachelle Ornan-Stone says...
A lot of it has to do with perception...
So something that I've been completely fascinated
by is visual perception, um, so tricks of
the eye, if you will.
Dr. Ornan-Stone works in Cabin Experience
at Boeing; she helps design the parts of the
plane that people interact with.
So, she's always thinking about how we use
the space in an airplane.
we've looked at the correlation between satisfaction
ratings of passengers with the width of the
cabin
at 50 inches above the floor.
Why 50 inches?
Because when you're seated in an airplane,
your eye line is about 50 inches from the
floor.
So, the engineers made that, the widest part
of the airplane's cabin.
We also use light as a really interesting
way of drawing the eye to the locations that
we want people to, to look at.
we think about all these subtle ways to affect
emotion.everyone appreciates a change of scenery
once in awhile and when you're on a really
long flight, um, to match lighting to the
activity that's going on is really important
and it marks parts of the journey for the
passengers as well.
When you enter a confined space like an airplane
cabin, engineers and designers use light and
structure to draw the eye upward.
But that's not all the lighting is for…they
can actually make these colors do anything.
Now, if an airline wants to do something different
or something wild, or have rainbows or have,
you know, crazy light shows, or something
like that, uh, that's fine too.
But you take something, you know, dynamic
like an Aurora Borealis, okay, I mean that's
something that's moving, it's beautiful, um,
and at the same time, it's still sky.
And these are just a few of their tricks.
See those indentations around the windows?
They draw the eye toward the window, so you
can see outside, it psychologically makes
your brain feel the space is larger.
They even designed the overhead bins to move
up and get out of the way adding to the visual
space…
You have all the stuff up and out of the way
and you have this beautiful light that draws
your eye up and, and above.
We know that from perceptual research, a well-lit
interior always looks more spacious.
As airplanes get more efficient and can stay
in the air longer, it's important to make
the airplane feel more comfortable.
Even making see-through curtains and barriers
can help you feel like you're in a bigger
space.
I love it when science is truly practical.
Thanks for watching DNews everybody, for more
about 100 years of Boeing Innovation go to
TheAgeOfAerospace.com.
And if you want to know how they built these
airplanes... we went to the factory!
You can watch that video, here.
Make sure you subscribe so you get all the
episode of DNews that we got coming at you.
Also, let us know down in the comments, what
was your most memorable flight experience?
Thanks for tuning in.
We'll see you next time.